this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by talk space
and upstart more on that later let's do
the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we
are
over here doing it at the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan sickler
on all social media ryansickler.com
make sure you subscribe to the youtube
channel that is where you will get video
every tuesday
of all these fantastic episodes all
right uh make sure you subscribe to the
patreon show where i do the honeydew
with y'all
it's called the honeydew with y'all
okay uh i try to just keep it real
simple i i
one time i was told that the pitch for
the movie aliens
was jaws in space and they were like
sold
three [ __ ] words that's what
i'm trying to do here you know what i'm
saying
um so yeah this the show is great it's i
charge five bucks a month that's it
it's one show a week it's 52 shows a
year it's 60 bucks and i know that is a
lot of money to some people but if you
have it that's all it is i'm not doing
[ __ ] tears and you know get a
[ __ ]
meet and greet and a t-shirt and all i
know five dollars a month all right
one show extra a week with y'all um
also facebook fan page all that stuff go
to the honeydewpodcast.com the links
for everything are there social media
the merch i again cannot thank you all
enough
for staying comfortable during this
virus and my night pants all right i
can't thank you enough the night shorts
are out there right now y'all are
looking great hoodies mugs all that
stuff it's all restocked
go get whatever you want um i record
here every week at the santa monica
music center
um if you want some online classes by uh
los angeles musicians no matter where
you live in the world
you just go to santa monica music dot
com use the code honeydew
and they'll waive the registration fee
and give you
i want to make it clear when i say this
one free lesson when you sign up for
your package all right
that is everything there now
this show is where we highlight the low
lights
and these are the stories behind the
storytellers and
i cannot wait to introduce you to
today's storyteller because she's
i think a four-pete on the feast and her
first time here on the honeydew ladies
and gentlemen
please welcome the queen of duke
[Laughter]
oh man this is i am very excited for
this because i was really you don't do
podcast as you said to me in the texts
i don't do podcasts i don't but i will
do yours
i've done them i'm done with them yeah
um so before we get into whatever we're
going to talk about today will you
please promote whatever you like because
you say you do have one you just
recorded right
oh yeah i just i was a co-host
for a podcast it hasn't come out yet
about the women's
suffrage movement um that comes out
august something
i can't think i honestly can't even
tell you the name of it because i'm so
like time
but if you go if you google women's
suffrage movement and retta
you'll find it that's good
you'll find it what else what else is oh
and then i'm um i'm on a show called
good girls
um it is
on netflix the first two seasons are on
netflix
and um the third season will come out
yeah on netflix just before the fourth
season
which we have to shoot four pete on
netflix too
oh man well it's an nbc show but
it gets put on netflix after it's so the
first runs nbc and then
and then so it's on netflix the first
three seasons are on netflix everywhere
but the united states the third season
will come out
just before the fourth season starts on
netflix in the u.s so you can get caught
up and then jump live in the season
yes great that's awesome good for you
and i am um the new voice
on rocket mortgage
are you really yeah i've done i i've
recorded three ads
um
i've recorded three ads and then i know
i have to do one more thing but only one
as far as i know only one has aired
um but i was my mother
calls me and she's like
cheryl from church just called and asked
if you were
on some commercial some rocket
commercial and i was like oh yeah yeah
she goes you are i was like yeah she's
like
oh and so and then like two weeks later
i was talking to her and she goes oh
do you know i have seen that commercial
so many times and i just realized it was
you
i was like really mom you didn't notice
me she's like
it's like yes i think they raised your
voice your voice is higher in it i go no
that's my commercial voice
she's like oh i i talked to your
father's like this our daughter
really that's what you told that
clueless both of them
[Laughter]
they're like as long as you can pay for
food we're good
um well there's a few things we're going
to talk about but speaking of your mom
you have a
you do have a really interesting story
about uh your mom
do you want to tell us about this um
you'd be my first story though my
um so when i was
my my parents my parents are from
liberia so
real quick because this is one of the
things that definitely stands out
liberia your mom's the peppa soup right
yes yeah okay well i mean there was a
song there's a liberian song
we'll make peppas right yeah so my mom
they might because my that's what my
father likes and my brother now likes to
but um so my parents are from liberia
and um i went there
i was there when i was
three months old you were born there or
they took you there right after
they i wasn't born there i was born in
newark new jersey
um don't be jealous the liberia of the
united states
pretty much there is a large liberian
community there
um or at least there was when i lived
there um
[Music]
but well i think i was like three months
old my mother took me there
um and then i was there
again for first grade
uh you actually went to school there for
first grade yeah i
well i my mother went back because
i i'm pretty sure it's because my
grandmother died her mom
died although she may have died when i
was three months and that's why
i was there for three months i can't i
never met i never
met her um so
my mother went back for something i'm
pretty i think it was
um my grandmother dying when i was in
first grade then she went back
when i was in fifth grade or just before
fifth grade
when my grandfather died and while she
was there
without you this time yes so she
both times the first time she went um
or rather when i was in first grade
uh she got stuck there
there's first of all there's there was
always turmoil and
you know unrest as far as i knew you
know growing up that's all i ever heard
about was always like
issues there and worried about getting
family
either out or getting things to family
because
the economy was bad blah blah blah and
so um
when i was in first grade she
went over there she got stuck there was
a coup both times where it was over
so the first time there was a coup she
got stuck
and she was depressed
and so they sent my brother so that she
had one of her kids
and then they sent me um because she was
like
she couldn't take it you know how long
do you know how long she was there
before you guys got there
i would say a couple of months damn yeah
yeah
and then so they sent me over and
i i was going into first grade
um so i ended up i had my uncle was
in um in the government
sort of uh and so while i was there i
went to first grade and i went to the
school where the government officials
kids
went to school so it was like this
private school i remember
i've told this story before i don't know
if i've told it
on the feast i feel like but i've told
it before
and so i re i was tall for my age
and you know in in these
old buildings the windows would open out
do you remember this story
i don't remember the story so the
windows would open out um
and when we were kids we would hold on
to ropes and then everybody
somebody would lead and then everybody
would just follow holding onto the rope
you know during recess or whatever
and because i was tall the kids walked
under the window
and i walked under the window and it
scraped the
top of my head off not the hole but
a big enough thing oh my my legs just
[ __ ]
but i was just took a chunk out of your
hair like it yeah it cut open like it
was a flap
i didn't notice i didn't well not that i
didn't notice
um i did notice i think the teacher must
have seen by the time we
went back inside i think the teacher
must have seen some blood
um and so i it's all
fuzzy i just know the part my mother
tells me for sure
and they kind of just like patched it up
really
bootleg style whatever and i went home
and i and went home this is in liberia
and so
i used to sleep in the bed with me and
my brother slept in the bed with my
mother
because my mother was staying with her
cousin so we were all in one
room and my mother says she
felt the bed wet no the pillow wet
and she turned on the light and saw the
pool of blood
like the the pillow was full with blood
they never told her that i got hurt
she didn't know what the she was like
what like freaked out
um and so you know woke me up and she's
like well i'm telling you what happened
yeah
it's like oh you know i just i still was
like kind of like
i hit my head on the window and then
another like went off on this school
um did she take you with her no no well
we went to a hospital we went to the
hospital so i could get
it taken care of and then another thing
crazy that happened during that time
so they had like kerosene stoves
there um i just remember such weird
things like
like them in the yard the way they had
it set up like
it was mostly family that lived in the
houses around it and so we had a
communal yard
until the women would cook together and
do stuff in the yard and
all this you know wash the clothes and
hang them on lines all back there it's
very
that is very vivid they used to catch
the chickens and cut the heads off and
pop them back there
um they hit the back of the yard
and um but we had kerosene stoves
and um someone had left the kerosene um
canister on the counter
and one day my brother comes into the
living room he was
little he comes into the living room
and uh i think he might have been one
year old
maybe maybe two no not i don't think he
was older because she had
when she had him she left so he i think
he turned one while we were there
and he was like she said he was gray
and he just he had pulled the kerosene
canister down and drank the kerosene no
so she had the russians we like we all
so many things happened to us when we
were in liberia without my dad there
um another thing my um my cousin who
lived it was a duplex so they lived next
door we'd go play next door
they because he was the smallest he
would be the baby when we played house
and she was going to give him a bath and
dropped him in a
in a zinc tub and busted open his lip
so another reason to go to the hospital
it was like so problematic anyway
that was the first time we were the
first time that my mother had to go over
there
when we were little the second time can
i ask you
those memories you actually have or a
little bit of hybrid you were
reminded or whatever the tub i remember
the the and the the kerosene
situation i just remember everybody
going crazy you know and screaming and
then picking him up and running out i
mean
that could be death yeah well yeah
um like i said the what do you remember
because you're first grade you have any
memories over there
like what stands out yes i remember the
the guy that used to
push the cart that used to bring you
know how you have like the ice cream
truck
well the he had coca-colas and
sugar cane so he had the cook the sugar
cane in the
ice so you would get it and you just
suck on cold
sugar cane oh that was a treat that was
a treat
um i sort of remember the market
um are there playgrounds or anything
like that like we have
we didn't know we didn't have i mean not
where we were particularly because we
were
out not deep country but we were in the
country
in this city we were outside of monrovia
so we weren't in the city city
um where it was like super busy i don't
like i don't remember
our street being busy a lot of traffic
i don't remember that but i also don't
remember
we must have had a car i don't have a
memory of a car yeah
i feel like i remember some people
having bikes but i don't remember
but i can't imagine that my aunt didn't
have a car
and i know my my grandfather but my
grandfather didn't live near us where we
were staying
um so i have like little any sports or
kids playing sports well soccer
they played soccer all the time you know
barefoot kick a ball
um yeah i don't have a whole lot
of the memories just little things and
it was so long ago
and and i don't have anybody
that i share the memories with right you
know like the little cousins that i
lived with
you know it's not like we've had
conversations about it over and over
it's just my mother perhaps telling
somebody else
what happened when we were little and
stuff like that and i'm like oh yeah
but yeah the the cutting of my head
i i think i have a memory of it because
of my mother
talking about you know i don't remember
the pillow being bloody right but i have
a memory of
my mother looking at me like you know
yeah
[ __ ] assault um
but um i ca and i can't even remember if
we all
went back the same time i think they
might have sent me back at what point
are you allowed to go back
i think they sent me back before and
then my mother um
came back with my brother a little bit
later i don't think i was there more
than a year because i feel like i know i
just only went to first grade
so and i'm honestly i don't even think i
don't even know if i finished first
grade i may have finished first grade
here in the states um but then she went
back again
later so then my grandfather died okay
and so she went back for that funeral
another well i think it was just before
i was in fifth grade because i started
fifth grade without my mom
so um there was another coup
while my mother was there it was like
every time she's
so much unrest um and so she got stuck
and she got stuck
she got stuck for longer so i feel like
she went
she might have gone for fourth grade or
i mean you know for the end of fourth
grade the very end of fourth grade
all through the summer me going into
fifth grade and being
in fifth grade you know i that's the
memory i have of being in fifth grade
and um coming home
one day so what what happens like the
government finally says all right this
you can travel now or it's safe to leave
or are you rolling the dice so here's
part of the thing
so um when
from what i know of it my mother didn't
become a u.s
citizen until i was i graduated from
college
whoa okay so my mother had a liberian
passport my mother was a student she
came to
the states for school so she always had
a green card
um and so
that's why you know my father became
became a citizen i think the the first
time you know
that they had moved here my mother was
on a green card
um so she did that why he stayed back
and
kept you guys no he stayed back because
he's working and needed to earn money
and
you know keep our apartment and that
kind of thing
um you know we were
it was you know struggle in the
beginning when they
when when they were young when we they
first came to the states
um but so
my because my mother had a liberian
passport
i don't know if it was particularly the
first time i don't know if it was
because
of the us or liberia but
when something goes something goes nuts
in a country
and they take over the government
there's no government so the system
[Music]
other countries can't trust that they're
running a
a real government right you know what i
mean sausage
so so you know you have these
um whether it be listen any librarians
who are
watching me i don't really know the
facts i'm just going by what i know
don't please do not call
or email him about how renata know what
the [ __ ] she's talking about because
there's always a honeydew live
phone call we don't want to really don't
know the details
but do not blow up the honeydew hotline
it makes sense to me
if a country is going through some kind
of takeover
they don't have the recognized
government that the other countries
recognized before
like listen there's a lot of [ __ ]
going on over there so good luck to him
we're not gonna let any of the crazies
come up you know they block
the you know you don't get the visas
yeah that's that's what's going on right
now they they're like there's
they got coveted in america and it's
bananas
y'all got to stay the [ __ ] out yeah
that's right so
when there's a coup someone takes over
the government
you know they kill the president and now
they're running things but they've never
run the country before they don't know
what's going on
you can't trust some and a lot of it
uh sometimes it's the new government
who who has taken over the country who
don't want
the old government escaping and so
people are not enough just so you're not
over some chat yeah they're like you
[ __ ] up this
for whatever reason whatever the reason
they're doing it they
you know and clues in in africa
are no joke you know i bet yeah yeah
it's bloody it's not cute
so did your mom do your mom ever share
anything about like
things she saw or had to deal with no
she hasn't but she's
she knows you know she knows people that
have and
stuff like that it's it's not you know
it's not an easy time obviously um
but whatever the case so then you so you
can't travel sometimes
you either can't come in or you can't
come out so because she had a liberian
passport she couldn't come into the
united states
so it had to get to a place where
they were finally letting and i don't
know if they had to you know my father
had to do
work on his and in the states saying the
mother of my children you
who are united states who are born here
who are you know
and i'm a naturalized citizen we need
her back that kind of thing
um so both times
like i said she's over there she has
libya and passports their coups
for um but for the second time when it
happened my father was not sending us
you know and i was a little bit older
you know
yeah um so i just remember
coming home in fifth grade one day
coming home from school
and i remember seeing a board game but
it was like
fancy it was like made with like this
wood
and had a wood stand and it had little
wood chairs you sit underneath you know
you sit low and you played again and i
remember the game from liberia it's
called ludo
and uh i remember it walking in and
seeing it and i was like
where'd that come from and then my mom
walked out from
the back room and i was like
yeah i hadn't seen um i mean what
months and months months and then
so my mother didn't drive at the
time so like whenever we went
grocery shopping to do the laundry we
had to go to a
you know a laundromat or whatever we'd
walk
go to the doctor's office doctor's
appointment we walked
and i remember walking to a doc and it
was not close
we lived in an apartment building and we
walked out of the complex
down the main road and i was like
where is this doctor who walks the
doctor's appointment and i remember
walking back and my mother says to me
well the rabbit died and i was like
that's something they would say when
someone was pregnant so my mother was as
soon as she got back she got pregnant
with my
youngest brother yeah um cause
my parents hadn't had sex
[Laughter]
it was on it popping
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that's what we're going to start
calling mitch
what's up cooking
[Laughter]
that is scary though it's weird that's
[ __ ] yeah i mean
i don't know anybody that has any
stories like that and they're like
i mean we sit here and think we're on
lockdown imagine that [ __ ]
yeah yeah every day fear
for your life probably can't go anywhere
one of the big things that my mother was
saying that was
when stuff like that goes down literally
it all it all falls apart like they were
like money didn't mean anything
because there was no true government no
one
they didn't believe in our currency you
know their their currency
she said they used to barter with
bullion cubes at the market
like that was that was considered cash
yep no [ __ ]
yep yeah that's crazy damn
i mean american dollars meant something
right the liberian money didn't nothing
until
things got back together yeah yeah
man that's great has your mom ever had
to go back since
or have you ever gone since no fifth
grade was
that was your last well actually i
wasn't there for i mean first grade was
that's the only thing
um really you're right maybe yeah um my
father has gone back a couple of times
um but uh my mother
my father wants to retire there but now
that they have grandparents my mother's
like i ain't gonna know where
just like unless we all go and we ain't
going
we're not all going so yeah but my
father goes back and
you see his family and stuff like that
that's great would you ever go back
um i might i actually there's um there's
a possibility of me going back
with covet things have gotten so thrown
but i was supposed to go back to do
this tv show thing um well not supposed
to
it was likely that i would go back to
for this tv thing
um but now it's kind of all in limbo
because of
you know this because the world's in
limbo and nobody wants us there
yeah yeah so but and from california
no you will wait we'll wait
[Laughter]
um all right i want to talk to you i had
asked you earlier
so loose it looks good on the girl
thanks um
i asked you about being bullied you said
no i wasn't bullied you brought up
college but let's go back
to where you went to college i still
think you're the only duke grad that's
ever been on
any of my podcast
[Music]
and i love that you're a duke grad but
um yeah what was college like for you
college was fun i loved college it was
you know i met
some of my closest friends that i'm
still friends with now
um had you did you drink it all in
college or anything
nothing no i i the first time i took a
drink
i like sipped a drink it was my freshman
year
i remember i was in a friend's dorm high
all college yeah in college and i was
like
um oh that's not true the first time i
took a drink
was i was senior in high school
and i sipped a cooler yeah and i was
like
that's what i was talking about you know
it's like whatever [ __ ] bottles and
james but then i think
i i think it might just no maybe i think
they had coolers but there was something
else i
drank like some vodka in some juice but
i didn't like it
and i was just hot the whole time swore
i was drunk everybody's like
you're just sweating you're not you know
like you're not drunk
um the first time i can say that i drank
drank
was was my 21st birthday or right after
my 21st birthday
um but i didn't drink in college i drank
after college like right after is when i
was making up for lost time
yeah i was like drinking you know
saint ides and boone's farm and
what was the uh what do they call it
liquid crack
oh um oh come on cisco cisco
all that trash
and we'll if there's one thing it will
guarantee do
is [ __ ] you up i
i is to paralyze me so it did
so kids say that's or not it you said
well
listen so we would play these like you
know you try to get that buzz real quick
before you go out so you don't have to
pay
for too many drinks while you're out
that program is real
and i remember sitting in my at my
friend's dining room table and we're
i don't know if we're playing quarters
or whatever just something stupid
just drinking and i just remember
i couldn't lift my arms and i was like
you guys i can't
i can't lift my arms and everybody's
like really i was like
i literally cannot lift
my arms i was like and then
it would go away it happened every time
everything but i also
yes so i used to i had to slow down on
the cisco i would drink other trash but
cisco used to freak me out well that one
is poison yeah
[Applause]
but i noticed i used to get that weird
paralysis thing
when i drank um
the wallaby darned at the outback which
was
oh what yeah which had the champagne it
had champagne
um peach schnapps
and another liquor frozen whatever and i
would get like a
like a weird like sensation like i don't
want to lift my arms
and then it would go away so i don't
know if there was some kind of
combination in cisco that was similar to
that
that was way stronger clearly because i
literally was like
i gotta drop out of college i can't move
my arms
ah that's a wrap but um
yeah it happened a couple of times like
that but then i
well i wasn't scared of it the second
time because i knew it would go away
bounce my quarter
exactly like i got you re-rigged
she's good you can't even point to them
[Music]
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor talk space now
we all have something we're working on
perhaps a career change
finding a partner or procrastinating
less the hard part isn't identifying
these goals it's taking action
thanks to talk space online therapy
finding a licensed therapist is easier
than ever
get matched with your perfect therapist
right from your device
and connect with them on your own
schedule from anywhere
at any time better yet one month on talk
space costs about the same amount as a
single in-person therapy
session talk space is a fraction of the
cost of in-person therapy but with
talkspace you can send unlimited
messages to your therapist and they'll
engage with you at least five days a
week
talkspace therapists have experience
treating depression anxiety
substance abuse trauma relationship
issues food and eating and much more
talkspace is secure and private using
the latest encryption technology to
store client information
the bottom line is that we all need
someone to talk to and talkspace wants
to give the license support we deserve
at a price we can afford as a listener
of this podcast you can get a hundred
dollars off your first month on
talkspace
to match with your perfect therapist go
to talkspace.com
or download the app make sure to use the
code honeydew
to get a hundred dollars off your first
month
and show your support for the show
that's honeydew
and talkspace.com our next sponsor is
upstart during these economically
turbulent times
everyone's looking for a way to feel
more financially secure so if you're
still needlessly throwing money
every month at high interest credit card
debt it's time you checked out upstart
the revolutionary
online lending platform that knows
you're more than just a credit score
now is the time to find out how low your
upstart rate can be to help pay off high
interest credit card debt unlike other
lenders upstart can reward you based on
your education and job history
in the form of a smaller rate but you
don't need a degree
or a diploma to apply though upstart
lets you skip going to the bank because
it's completely online they offer loans
from a thousand dollars
to 50 000 so you can consolidate your
debt
into one easy fix rate payment upstart
makes it fast and simple to check your
rate and since it's just a soft pull
it does not affect your credit score the
hard pull happens if you accept your
rate
and proceed with your application the
best part
if the loan is approved and accepted
most people are getting their funds the
very next business day
over 400 000 people have used upstart to
pay off credit cards or meet their
financial goals free yourself from the
burden of high interest credit card debt
and get back to using your money your
way with upstart i know some of you guys
have you've hit me up about it told me
how easy it was
um so thank you for supporting the show
and i'm glad it's working out for you
um and you can see why upstart has a 4.9
out of 5 rating on trustpilot
and hurry to upstart.com honeydew to
find out how low
your upstart rate can be checking your
rate only takes a few minutes that's
upstart.com honeydew
now let's get back to the do yeah
but did you go out and hang out and
stuff too you just didn't drink
yeah i just didn't really so you were
social drink yes yes i was social
i can't remember does duke even have uh
fraternity sororities
yeah they do yes we have fraternity
fraternities and sororities
um when i used to go to the you know
frat parties or whatever and we were you
in a sorority no
and we used to go to uh chapel hill all
the time
yeah so right you got what's the in
proximity you've got nc state right
you got north carolina chapel hill there
you got duke
now is something else there's i mean
well those were the
the i mean you know wake forest is not
that far
um in greensboro there's a lot of
colleges
you know nccu but how quickly are you
going duke to
chapel uh 13 minutes oh holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's
nothing like going to west hollywood
from here yeah
they're really close so we used to go we
go to parties over there all the time
these kind of parties to us all the time
um but the whole
uh bullying thing
you know being a fat girl in in
college and mind you i'm bigger than i
was when i was in college
i you know i just got bigger when i uh
went to college um and
hey you know you go out and you're with
all your girlfriends and you're with the
cute girls
and so i would have um
you know guys who try to get to you
through your friends you know by
trying to buy you a drink you know try
so what you know lean past you and
you're like
did you need me to move you know like
how much are you like having a
conversation around my face
yeah exactly um but i remember having
this
incident at oh gosh what was the name of
the place
it was on franklin street
upstairs
i keep wanting to say charlie good night
which is the club that i used to do
in raleigh north carolina but it's
oh i can't even think of it anyway
um so this guy tried to talk to my
friend
lika lika is new jersey
she's mixed she's asian and white
but she's so ghetto
right and she's to mess with black guys
all the time
and so this black guy was trying to talk
to her
she wasn't interested and she was like
get the [ __ ] up out of my face
oh and she's like i'm good bruh
kind of thing and i was like i'm always
like nervous because anywhere
lika goes there's gonna be a fight she
this small scrappy it's always fighting
um so this guy's trying to talk to her
she's not interested he's
doesn't appreciate it
he's getting in her face
and she she's like and as soon as
she starts [ __ ] then she starts
reading everything about him you know
little dick [ __ ]
your fake cross colors your this your
that that gold that chain ain't gold
all the things and he's not feeling it
and he goes for her throat
not with me around i remember i was
wearing a baseball cap
i was wearing a baseball you're right
there he didn't
i'm not really paying attention until
she starts getting loud
with him and i turn and i see him go
and my friends so when i get mad
something like and i
have no fear and normal i'm a scaredy
cat what's that all about
my no fear thing i have a thing of of
like fairness and equality and i'm and
i'm and as soon as i see something
that's not fair or not right especially
like it's getting violent and you know
it's in it
it's disrespectful it's like the whole
thing i
get so angry and so i don't have that
but where do you think that comes from
i don't know because i have the same
thing where also it's i get stubborn too
like there was a gas station in my
neighborhood
for i i didn't i didn't know how long i
didn't i'll tell you what i didn't plan
on living in a neighborhood for 10 years
but i did
and one time i went to get a bottle of
water and the goddamn machine wasn't
working i was dying of thirst and i just
went to the window and i go yo
machine took the dollar just it's in
just can i please get a bottle of water
he's like
i ain't my machine and i was like right
away
i go look i get that you're you're you
know subcontracting your real estate
over here
come on the dollar's in there like it
costs a dollar for a bottle of water in
your place can you just take the dollar
i don't have the keys and i'm like this
[ __ ] and now there's people
behind me and i just
i just lost my [ __ ] i'm like you know
what [ __ ] you [ __ ]
i'm never coming to get gas here let me
tell you something i would if i was on
fumes i would have pushed my car by that
gas station
two times in 10 years i had to go and i
felt guilty about those two
but that gas station lost a lot of money
on my ass
principal is what i was looking for yeah
i'm very all about principles yes i'm
with you i i
100 sum to a fault sometimes so
i like you know you get that
your heart starts racing the blood
rushes in and my friends say
that i said not today [ __ ] and i
turned the hat
backwards i turned the hat backwards
and i [ __ ] went at him
and he was a little bit shocked
as it is but i it just spills out
and i go so then security that like the
whole place is like what the [ __ ]
there no fight really happened i just
jumped at him and i'm like [ __ ] you the
[ __ ] you think you're are you a [ __ ]
fighter girl she's [ __ ] five two [ __ ]
you
going on at night we're hitting some of
her highlights
and here's what i remember because he
had said to me earlier something about
do you know michael bivens or bell bib
development yeah
and i said i know ralph and i said
imagine what you really do
[Laughter]
and i remember saying well we're not pen
pals i know who he is
did he go to school there no but he was
trying to say
that was one of his things about being
cool was he's friends with michael
what gives a [ __ ] meaning you know who
that guy is that's my buddy yeah
yeah like but he wasn't there right yeah
he was just
saying that's like you know my
girlfriend lives in canada he was just
saying he was trying
and i was like this is how you try to
pull girls do you know michael bivens
so when i jumped on it was one of those
things that was like you pretend you
don't even know michael
like who cares no i don't even care but
i was like going
crazy and i just try to get her off me
man i remember security pulling us apart
what a dumb thing and then throwing him
out
i mean him being like yelling like she's
the one who tried to jump me
i was like yeah [ __ ] but i come here
all the time
they like me bye
bell biv devoe yeah now you know
[Laughter]
see that we got a little bit out of it
man so
did you date it all door in college no
i hooked up every once in a while but i
never dated anyone
so how would you meet guys what was your
way of me because back then
no offense i'll say bad things i'm in
that class too but it wasn't a
let's just get online and see who's out
tonight you know and who's in my
proximity like
it was just basically
parties yeah go ahead party no no
parties
party it was more of a party thing and
you know you just meet somebody and
you knock out or whatever um
i also didn't hook up with a lot of
people in college
i don't know i was a little bit of an
introvert i was a
you know i was a goody two-shoe so i
wasn't just gonna have sex with
you know a bunch of randoms i just
remember whenever a friend told me
like if they they met somebody when we
were out and they met somebody
and they kind of hooked up and then like
we talked the next day
and i'm like you had sex with him
you don't even know that was my big my
friends used to make fun of me
like you don't even know him i remember
you saying that i always feel like
back when that was a place and uh you
used to tell me that [ __ ]
made me laugh but you're like he put his
mouth where you got a straw you had a
straw
and you just kept asking questions
[Music]
[Laughter]
little there that became a little hoe
there i was like oh i get it
i get it i get it
[Music]
it's fun it's um the random hookup i
want
you said two things you mentioned
introvert and goody two shoes
why um why were you goody two shoes were
you raised like
what was it more about not letting mom
and dad down or not about letting them
find out
like whoa you both but yeah but
i mean it was always about like
not embarrassing my parents but you're
also a duke
you know i want to nobody gives a [ __ ]
if you don't finish community college
you know i mean duke's a big deal
especially
coming from where your parents came from
yeah
but honestly i don't think duke was that
big a deal to my parents they were just
like college
so you know it was a bigger deal to me
than it was to them my parents would
just like go to college
um we need to be able to afford it so if
you don't get
you know financial aid kind of thing um
but it was yeah it was the way i was
raised i think
always in the back of my mind you know
what would debbie
think if she if she found out about it
it's one of the reasons i didn't
why i didn't curse for so long when i
got older and i was like
um then i i cussed so much you're good
at it
but um but otherwise i remember
the first time i heard my mother say ass
i was in college and she was mad about
my dad about something
and was she was an ass i swear me and my
brother were like
you had never heard that and then i
remember
telling my mom a joke some stupid joke
about
monkeys in a cage throwing poop and i
said [ __ ]
and she was like oh i'm done with this
joke who are you talking to
he's like we ain't we are not equal
we do not i was like lord and i was
in college oh yeah i was in college then
i was like all right dab we got it cool
cool cool
cool but has she ever seen you do stand
up or your work now
well she's yeah she's seen my work now
she did see me do stand up
because i my mother was then to my
mother's forever about school
like africans live for school so my
mother was in
at the insurance college in new york and
um and i had a gig there so she came to
that show but my mother
saw me do stand up in north carolina
where i started at charlie good night's
um so i told my mother
this is a good story i think i may have
told you this too
when i first started doing santa my
parents are in jersey i'm in north
carolina
and i'm about to do my first show and
i've written this bit
it's my kfc bit and worked really hard
on it
and i tell my mother the bit on the
phone
silence and she's like
i mean hi [ __ ]
i guess it could be funny you know and
this is like
i always thought i was about to kill
this [ __ ] you know it's my clothes
so it was the time i was doing open mic
it was time i was doing open mic so i
was getting ready to do it
at an open mic i went and did it killed
killed like ripped it's still that bit
still works that's how strong
2020 is still right so
take that i go home
i call my the next day i tell her about
it i was like i can't i did so well
people really thought it was and my
mother was like well there's no
accounting for taste
and i was like they're wrong she said
she really was like
i don't know what's going she came she
and my dad came to north carolina to
visit me
i'm you know i had made sure i had a set
so i i had a set i was the oh i was the
emcee
so i opened the show i did well but
whatever
worst thing in the world my mother my
parents were sitting in the front
you don't answer questions you don't
answer
comics questions at the club
oh so he's asking about their sex life
and i'm like having a [ __ ] fan like
that i mean my mother is
she's not my mother's super religious my
father doesn't talk
so it was just anyway
glad that was over and we got out of
there
and i was like mom just future reference
you never talk
during a cup unless you want to be in
the show don't sit down don't say
anything don't sit in front
she had to sit in the front see me yeah
anyway i said what did you think of my
session
funny i guess she has to be there to
enjoy it i was like yeah i guess so
but i was like yeah it's a good bit
always works
i'm dusting off right now
um can we talk about
the the loss of your friend
i i asked you about something and you
said yeah it was a really tragic
thing and i just i wanted to know if we
could talk about that um yes
so i had you know i have a really good
friend who
whose baby passed away he was
two and you were you were asking like
any traumas back when you said you
didn't have i was like and i was like i
don't really have any dramas and i was
like oh yeah like
because i because it wasn't my child i i
don't think of it as my trauma you know
even though it was like the worst
experience yeah it was certainly
one of my worst experiences and it
wasn't my
child exactly um but that was
that was a tough scary time because
you're worried about your friend getting
through it
um what happened
um oh god no i'm scared i'm gonna cry um
so her son had been sick
i remember um
so i was at red rock and
she used to dj and so she was dj she
wasn't there that night
her husband was there filling in and i
was like
where is she's like oh the baby's sick
so she stayed home the next day i wake
up
to a call from one of our good friends
and she says
she's she's kind of crying and she's
like um
the baby died and i was like what and i
like i was like let me i'm trying to
wake up and i'm like what are you
talking about
she goes last night they were in the
hospital
and he died
last night and i was like what are you
talking about what are you talking about
and like i had to get off the phone i
literally remember just sitting
for a while and just being like this
can't be true this can't be true you
know like having a little bit of like
palpitations trying to become and then
calling her phone she didn't answer
calling his phone he didn't answer
um i called my friend back and she's
like yeah i said well
what okay where are they now where are
they now she goes jaclyn just talked to
them
jacqueline talked to them last they were
still in the hospital when
she talked to him so i called jacqueline
and she's like yeah it's [ __ ] up she's
and jaclyn lives
out far um so i'm like
freaking out freaking out freaking out
and i'm like praying as if she didn't
already tell me what happened you know
i'm praying like it can't be true it
can't be true
like [ __ ] freaking out i remember i i
got off the bed and sat on the floor
and i was like can't be true i can't be
treated what is going on what is going
on
and then i called her number again
she didn't answer
and i called it so it was like texting
back and forth everybody trying to
figure out where they are
a whole thing so i would say about an
hour and an hour and a half
from when i first got the call to when i
tried to call them
again i call her no answer i call him he
answers
and i'm like where like what what
happened he's she and he's very calm you
can tell he's like
[ __ ] up and he's calm and he's like
he's like yeah
we just got home she's in the bed she's
in the bedroom
and she and
she's kind of wailing in the back
um and she's just like who is it who is
it and she's like
and he tells her it's me and she's like
and i said
i said should i come over and he said
should i come over and she yells yes
so i was the first person to go over
there
and it was just this most surreal like
when i think about it
it almost has this like ethereal feeling
because i just remember it
like we weren't really there like it not
that it didn't happen but it was
it i get this like weird feeling because
like we just floated through that whole
thing because
like you were almost watching it so we
were there right literally
what do you mean like you're almost view
you're outside of it
not so much that i was outside of it but
i that i
i almost didn't let myself i won't let
myself hold on to it
we were we were we i would say i was at
the house probably for three days
there were people in and out of the
house
constantly people coming flying in
the traumatic part about it like it was
it was
it it was [ __ ] traumatic the hard
part to watch
was every time someone knew
came in it was their time
to go through it so she had to go
through it every
time someone came in to the room so it
started to get
really really [ __ ] heavy like and so
so then we're just
in the house so it's it was probably
like seven or eight girls of
um like in the bedroom just in the
bedroom
we'd go out every once in a while to get
something all the guys were outside
in the living room and in the kitchen
and stuff like that but the girls were
in the bedroom most of the time
we're on the floor on the bed we're
sitting in the chat like and there was
this one girl
who she flew in um
i think she got there on the third day
and um you know she was good friends
with her she
she had been in her wedding i don't know
if they'd both been in each other's
wedding but
she had kids and you know so she had to
find
i think her husband was taking care of
the kids so she flew in
so she's new we've been grieving for
three days
like it has been [ __ ] heavy and we
had finally gotten to a point
where we were laughing about stuff so
telling stupid stories
and like on the crying lap but dying
laughing
and i remember her coming into the room
and being
irate that we are
cracking up that was her first
impression of
well she had been there she probably had
been there for like two or three hours
but she hadn't been in the day
yeah but she hadn't even been she hadn't
been in the room really
and i mean like cackling
like it was weird but we had
it been so [ __ ] [ __ ] heavy for so
long
like the fact that we were even finding
stuff to laugh with
you know and you know my friend was in
the bed she and she was laughing she was
crying but she was laughing too
so she comes in and it's like
what is going i don't even understand
what is going on in here like
she came in like somebody's parent like
it was a slumber party and we were told
to go to bed an hour ago
[Laughter]
and i snapped
turn the hat around
i might have taken the hat off
so
everybody so everybody got really weird
everybody was like what the [ __ ] she's
like
yeah how do you handle this like and i
was like how do you
i turned her and i was like if you don't
get the
[ __ ] out of here i said we have been in
this
[ __ ] room sitting in this [ __ ] for
three days
you just walked in this [ __ ] and you
want to tell somebody
you want to tell people how to [ __ ]
agree go and grieve yeah
we're in here with the mother
who [ __ ] needs this reprieve and
you're gonna
how if i said [ __ ] i will [ __ ] choke
you out in front of this all these girls
in this room if you don't get the [ __ ]
out of here
right the [ __ ] now
and she was like salty you know like
and i said get the [ __ ] out
wow she walks out
you know so i'm like and i turn around
and they all fall out laughing like
it's like the [ __ ] i mean and then of
course i was i laughed about it i was
like
how dare you and literally and then my
friend
[Laughter]
oh my god we were what happened that
lady stay
like did you have to go see her after
that
she
you probably scared the [ __ ] out of that
like i mean but yeah i was like
y'all need anything
[Applause]
what are you doing oh god
yeah that was it was um
i've never like had to
function in that kind of grief before
it was really hard and i was working
so i had to go shoot like i was on parks
at the time
and i just remember being in hair makeup
and they were like okay well
we won't put on eyeliner like i was just
crying constantly and then just
like the last minute they're like
eyeliner and then i have to go on set
like action treat yourself can i tell
you
i wish you would have been able to
[ __ ]
copyright that i hear it everywhere and
you know when i hear someone say it so
i'm like you know what that's from
they're like what i'm like that's from
retta
i'm parker i don't know i don't give a
[ __ ] he does deserve so too but it's
always you when i say and i'm like
that's from right on parks and rec that
is stolen [ __ ] written from somebody
that is their [ __ ]
nobody even knows where a [ __ ] comes
yeah a lot yeah my friend um
she said she was at the grocery store
this is years ago
and uh she
she had just gotten this like uh manny
manicure
that had like these glittery this
glittery polish on and she
put something out and the cash cashier
said
oh i like your uh your polish she was
like oh yeah
i got a day at the salon and the bagger
was like treat yourself
and she was like that's my friend he was
like who's your friend
he's like my friend treat yourself he's
like
no idea didn't know if that it came from
a show where it came from it was just
this thing that was in the zeitgeist at
that point and uh
she was like never mind yeah but treat
yourself yes that's what i did
um not to go back to your
great friend of mine a very good friend
of mine the lady i considered my mom
growing up her daughter passed away
she was a sister to all of us like 16
and a half actually was i shouldn't just
say her daughter passed away
it was two friends of ours in a car
accident um
that the a guy crossed the center line
hit them
he was ejected died immediately she was
uh and no airbags back then anything
they they hit heads
and then bang so she was you know
it really [ __ ] her head up and she was
on life support for a little while and
then she passed away
and and for me that was just a run
of it went from my dad at 16
and then to my grandmother in april a
few years later
she was i believe august and then my
other grandmother in
like october all that same year and i
was like what the [ __ ] like
and i remember his mom because it was
like you said the house so many people
coming in and out
everyone meaning well and his mom um my
friend shannon like his
he's the guy i'm still close with her
it's
so kelly and so shannon my friend uh
his mom her brother um we're still super
tight and
i just remember everyone being there
kids are you know just high school
that's different when it's in high
school so now the kids are sleeping over
and you know on the
ten of them on the floor you know yeah
and um she asked me and i don't know
she and i have talked about it and i i
said why'd you ask me for that and she's
like we just take me out for a drive
and i was like yeah and i took her out
and i don't know we were just driving
and she's just crying
and she's yeah and she's just crying and
i'm
you know i don't know what to [ __ ]
say i'm not even a parent let alone lost
a child i have
no idea what to say and um
i end up driving and i don't know why i
did this but
just because it was in the air like to
our high school and i just thought i'll
just park here on the parking lots
lights and you know some other cars
stuff there
and she puts on garth brooks the dance i
had never heard that song before in my
life
and this woman i mean screamed
just a primal guttural
and i was like oh you didn't want anyone
to see you do this i get it and i just
sat there and
i was just like whoa i will never forget
that like
hearing that just like wailing yeah and
we're in the honda civic you know what
i'm saying
it was tight quarters it was some close
ass car
for that trauma that 1990 honda civic
with original rims
so you say
original red always original red like
that's fly
like it was limited edition hey listen i
stayed true you know what i'm saying
everybody trying to get your [ __ ]
hubcaps and your spitters and all i stay
true to my og
bridge they spin the [ __ ] they're
spinning
their people out there and still have
that [ __ ] on their car
because they spent the money they're
coming back
they're coming back they are not coming
i see old cabs every now and then
look at this cab trying to get you
that's hilarious
didn't you say you had two friends who
lost yeah and then i had another
friend they you know they
when they had twins and one of the girls
she had issues from the beginning so she
was you know in the hospital
for a long time from birth and then
finally um she was able to
get out and she still had some more
surgeries to go
and i think it was like after her second
birthday
things went downhill and they were back
in the hospital and she passed away
and i was like how i used and i used to
um when i was touring
um on the road i remember i would i
would see these families
in the airport with their kids
and i remember you know it was right
then i felt that
ticking clock for having kids or
whatever
and after that after both those losses
um i was like i wouldn't be able to
survive it
it's probably for the best that i don't
have kids you know what i mean like i
i got over that ticking clock because i
was like
i don't i don't know how people survive
it
it looks it changes you being a being a
good parent
good one not one it's just like peace
you know brought you here good luck you
know being a good parent changes
everything about you it
exposes all of your insecurities you
find out [ __ ] you never knew about
yourself
um you know it's humbling it's difficult
and i mean just my daughter's five she
don't leave the [ __ ] house
you know i can't imagine what that's
going to feel like every [ __ ] night
hoping they come home safe every [ __ ]
time they leave
when you're in high school and you're
like why are you celebrating
yeah and then i i'm an aunt and i'm like
right that's how it started for me yeah
being an uncle and then you're like
sick tonight my nephew we found out my
nephew had cancer two years ago
oh my god and it was leukemia and he's
doing well
good you know hopefully by october
next year he should be done with his all
right um
chemo and stuff um
but just the random crying
like you feel sick
i'm an auntie and i'm like i can't even
imagine
being the parent and then having you
know
had two friends one very close friend
lose a child to see it to
be there for experience it the fear that
i have my nephew
like right and you don't want your mind
to go there at all
but you can't help it
i every time i get off the phone with my
nephews i'm like i love them so much
it's so bad oh my god my my first nephew
went to kindergarten last year
they have a video of him getting on the
bus i bawled
bald cry he's so small the other girl is
so dumb
oh god it is i don't know how parents do
it oh
therapy i went right my daughter almost
got hit by a car it unhinged me it
unhinged me
and i went to emdr therapy and she's
like look you're future tripping you're
you're programmed to feel a certain way
about things because
death and destruction you know is what
you know
and that didn't happen but i couldn't
stop seeing that horrible scene play out
and it didn't even happen
right and you know there was clearly
some anxiety and [ __ ] that had just been
just just been chilling down there like
oh we wake up
wake up don't worry it's been good down
here the whole time
we're coming and it did with a full i
started getting scared of flying
i had never been scared never i loved
that [ __ ] take off and then i was
like
what was that you know what any every
bump i hear y'all
yeah that's when my panic and i fl you
know
road coming i tour that's all i did was
travel
my commute was to the airport
and after that i used to get i now i'm
scared like i hate
turbulence even though like do you do
this when you when you feel turbulence
you're like
there's gonna be another one coming you
feel the other one you're like it's
probably another one
and you're like okay maybe one more and
then you're like okay and then it
smooths out and you're like okay so i'm
then something comes and you're like
yeah i've screamed on a plane before
i've screamed i'll do this too i grab
and look see if anybody else is scared
like i'm trying all right he's still
reading the paper over there
i watch i keep an eye on the you know i
like to i
generally fly first so generally fly
first don't worry about it
don't worry about it i'm back there keep
an eye on you
i stare at the flight attendant um
when there's turbulence and as long as
she stays calm i can
kind of stay calm i was on a flight
to amsterdam klm flight
turbulence was [ __ ] up and
the purser comes
running down the aisle running down and
i'm like
running on a plane to get to the thing
to say get in your seats get it
and i'm right by where that mic thing is
and i was like
i'm pretty sure that's not how you
handle this yeah i was
the old man was crying next to me crying
yeah he i think it was his first flight
i don't think he'd phone
his left all right he was like i don't
know if he's going to make it
with me here i come
i just remember being like this woman
but i honestly i think that made me feel
and this is before this was before i was
really scared to fly i think
but that is what made me like be able to
watch calm
flight attendants and stay calm even
though i was feeling
shit's bouncing they're still back there
porn coffee i'm like we're good
like i just yeah janice had done been
through this a bunch yeah
yeah i i get so like fear of heights i
started getting scared of heights when i
never been
scared of heights before i'm like what
is going on
it's quite hard
i used to love to fly i loved turbulence
the more
better when i was younger oh yeah oh
yeah like you're right of it
oh i love it because you don't have the
fear of death as a kid
no you know i yelled on a plane i've
told this before but i'll that's a quick
one you'll laugh at this so
i have that anxiety you know and um now
with this whole blood disease i have
found out i had i got to get up and walk
every goddamn 90 minutes and [ __ ] i'm
the [ __ ] in the back you know
chatting them up because i gotta be bad
i'm stretching i'm
doing got my my [ __ ] compression
pants on and [ __ ]
you're compressing i have to wear them
you almost like pants
yeah i gotta wear compression pants you
wear pants over them or do you just wear
a snug
can you imagine if i didn't i do i swear
bike shirts
what's up everybody i can always get the
middle seat next to me
i get poor man's first class don't worry
about it
but one time i'm sleeping and now also
because of the i'm also a courteous
person because of i i do like to sit in
the window seat
and i like to try to sleep but i can't
sleep now because i got to get up every
night
so now i don't want to walk across
everybody i sit in the aisle
i sit in the aisle also and you know
that just doesn't make me feel as secure
i know it's so dumb we're going a
thousand miles an hour anything hits
it's over
i ain't the window ain't gonna save me
you know what i mean nothing
but in my mind i feel less secure in the
aisle seat but i sit there anyway you
know
at one time i guess i fell asleep but
in my mind we are we're headed to
baltimore you know what i mean and we
are up there and all of a sudden the
plane just
and i mean it is uh 747 nose diving
i haven't had that in the real world in
my life and i went
and i mean i woke myself up and i looked
around listen
everybody like a lead and i'm like
oh red listen we still had four hours to
go
girl i took my hoodie up with this [ __ ]
and i just laid there i didn't take
drinks nothing just no i'm sorry
everybody
i had the same thing i i like the window
as well
um part of it is like if there's
turbulence
when i if i can see the ground for some
reason
a little bit steadier too i don't yes if
i'm in the clouds i'm like we don't know
what's going on
i've seen through i've seen other planes
and i'm like why was that their plane
was closed i
once i saw plane i was like that plane
wasn't supposed to be there
like really yeah i saw a plane go by and
i was like that's too
close there's too much sky for that
plane to have been where it was like i
was like something's up but
i'd fallen asleep at the window
turbulence i think there must have been
some turbulence i don't think it was
that bad
but in my dream in my sleep i
felt it and i felt a drop and i screamed
too and i was like
and the person next to me
you know kind he was kind and like okay
like i was like
but no one else really reacted but i was
just like
oh gosh i i remember
i i used to find chicago all the time i
felt i flew american
and so you know chicago is a big hub
over there
and uh the wind shears
i've i was on a flight once that tried
to land three times
no [ __ ] that i hate that one
because i just want to get down when
even when they go oh we gotta go back up
and around like
that's
[Music]
i remember getting off the plane i was
crying crying crying i was in the
hallway you know having gotten off the
plane away from the
gate in that hallway towards the
uh mrs fields i remember seeing mrs
field
sitting i sat down on the heater that
was along the window
i called my age and said cancel the rest
of my shows i'm done
i don't know how i'm getting home but
i'm done i'm not getting another [ __ ]
plan he's like
calm down get to the hotel
do your show we can talk about it when
you get back i said well
i'm probably driving back so it's gonna
be
i was just and i'll never forget that
day
i had um i was doing this show and
what so what's the kid from saved by the
bell with the
squirrely afro screech it was dustin
diamond dustin diamond was also
on this show i don't remember what he
did or whatever
he went on after me because he was a
bigger name and um
i was like yeah i'm done my stand-up
career is over
it wasn't but i was messed up
wind cheers [ __ ] that i hate flying
chicago
i just want to say right now like i
really miss stand up i miss the art of
grabbing a microphone and getting up on
stage and rocking a mic
and making an audience laugh for an hour
i miss it
i missed the [ __ ] out but i also
realized today too like
what a joke all of this whole life thing
it like
did did i just put my whole life and
passion
into an art form that could be gone
i mean think about that like you know
i'm a kid my whole life all i've ever
wanted to be was this thing this thing
this thing this thing
this this gone it's just gone like it
could be so
now i'm like [ __ ] it live your life
however the [ __ ] you want to live and do
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do
i don't even know if you should dream
anymore i don't even know if you should
dream
i mean corona gonna come along kill my
dreams
i was just i was just with a friend of
mine we were talking about
um she's an actor too
and we were talking about like red
carpets and stuff like that
um and it's how we would tell people is
like it's not it's all it's cracked up
to be you know it's not as glamorous so
it's not as glamorous as it looks
and i was like yeah we were probably
salty just before we got out of the car
kind of thing and then we were talking
about the
photographers and i'm like what are
those
photographers doing like
that was their job to go to these events
take pictures sell the pictures earn
money
churches all of it all these jobs all
these passions all these human beings
have had
all these occupations and jobs and
dreams
a lot of them could be gone so
how do you tell your kids you can be
anything
but that [ __ ] could be taken away from
you for nothing
for a virus um all right i wanna i wanna
wrap this up with you but before we do i
wanna ask you
advice you would give to your 16 year
old self what
what the hindsight you now have what
would you say
i always say patience um
my big thing was you know i wanted to
become an actor i wanted to be a
successful actor
and um so you know so
that's why i started stand up because i
you know my
path i thought was to have my own sitcom
and i was i had anxiety
and not anxiety that it wasn't happening
i believed it was going to happen
my anxiety was when's going to happen
what's going to happen what's going to
happen
and so i would tell my younger self
just chill it's gonna happen you know
even though i
i knew deep deep down i was like it's
kind of
up under that tomahawk cut your head up
there
thunder it was gonna happen
yeah and so
because i really don't feel like i had
any doubt i
i honestly felt like i'm gonna figure
something out probably
but i felt like i knew it was gonna
happen
just calm down let the
let that anxiety go um now i have
anxiety for a whole
different reason you know yeah next year
trying not to capture disease
yeah that's great thank you thank you
for coming on
i'm serious i know you don't do podcasts
i know you don't it's exclusive over
here
thank you um as always ryan sickler on
all social media ryan sickler.com we
will talk to you all next week
[Music]